en la co27 ha habido varios llamados
para que los bancos multilaterales de
desarrollo aumenten sus inversiones En
la lucha climática de hecho el propio
director gerente de operaciones del
Banco Mundial recriminó que no exista
ningún financiamiento que esté yendo al
África subsahariana y retó a los países
con más recursos económicos a que hagan
más y dirijan más dinero hacia proyectos
en esta región a través de su entidad
sin embargo el aumento de financiamiento
climático de los bancos multilaterales
solo alcanzó los 40.000 millones de
dólares en 2018 y se redujo a 35.000
millones en 2020 una inversión que tan
solo supone un tercio del total de las
operaciones de estas entidades para
entender lo insuficiente que es esta
cifra el monto calculado para que los
países en desarrollo consigan cumplir
con sus objetivos de reducción de
emisiones alcanza los dos billones de
dólares lo mismo A lo que ascendió el
gasto militar Global en 2021 Así que el
dinero está ahí Simplemente hay que
redirigirlo Franz 24 habló con el banco
asiático de inversión en infraestructura
sobre de qué pueden hacer estas
instituciones en la lucha climática hay
dos cosas que los bancos multilaterales
pueden hacer por los países más pobres
una es ese tipo de dar la financiación
más barata para la otra es axely sacar
bajar el riesgo de estas inversiones
porque las inversiones María todavía son
muy riesgosas en clima No todavía
tenemos que hacer cosas con tenemos que
hacer cosas que todavía no sabemos si
van a funcionar Entonces eso también le
tenemos que dar a los países y creo que
nuestra oportunidad ahora que es es para
precisamente para hacer eso se han hecho
muchos comentarios y muchos convinden en
temas de financiamiento ahora tenemos
que mover ese capital No es cierto lo
tenemos que mover como bien dijiste vos
en temas de que sean a fondo pero para
que la financiación climática sea
asequible lo que se está exigiendo es
que esta no llegue en forma de préstamos
que engrosan las deudas externas de los
países en desarrollo como se está
haciendo en un 70%, sino que llegue en
forma de becas a cambio de acciones
climáticas que contribuyen a reducir las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
en el planeta